what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of very
important details about the Kang Dynasty
our next Avengers film which is not too
far away right now the cast and the crew
of Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania are
still doing press interviews so we are
consistently getting new information
about Kang the Conqueror but also about
what the future holds for Kang because
the writer for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania Jeff loveness is also
writing Avengers the King Dynasty so of
course naturally many people are taking
these opportunities and interviews with
him to ask about what to expect for the
Kang Dynasty and although of course he
can't really give anything away he has
told us a little bit about what to
expect from the film and what to expect
from King and if you liked Avengers
Infinity War which many people do
consider that to be pretty much the best
MCU film there is so far then it sounds
like there is going to be a lot of
similarities between Avengers Infinity
War and the King Dynasty and also
between Thanos and King and also
something to keep in mind for Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania also spoilers
incoming if you haven't seen that movie
yet when asked about Kang's ending in
quantumania on whether or not he was
actually dead or not he responded by
saying you don't want to know the answer
to that so of course many fans right now
believe that Kang simply just got sucked
further into the quantum realm and that
he is not actually dead after all
quantumania did tell us that there are
essentially layers upon layers upon
layers in the quantum realm there are
many different parts and sides to it so
I'm thinking that the king that we saw
in quantumania is still around and the
reason that in the Kang Dynasty we are
going to get a Kang and our main
Universe Earth 616 universe is because
the Kang from quantumania could be out
for Revenge he could get out and want to
go seek revenge on Janet on Scott on
Cassie the entire Ant-Man family and of
course while he's there he might as well
beat the Avengers quantumania showed us
and the post-credits scene made it very
clear that Kang and multiple versions of
Kang have always been able to beat the
Avengers wherever they have been in
whatever Universe they have defeated the
Avengers many many many times however
now a Kang has been defeated by The
Avengers in a certain Universe our
universe well at least in the quantum
realm a hero from our universe beat them
and the reason I think it's probably the
same Kang is what writer Jeff lovnes has
recently said about Kang and the Kang
Dynasty apparently in the Kang Dynasty
Kang is going to be a hero not
necessarily to The Avengers but to
himself and to the Multiverse as he
knows it in Kang Dynasty Kang is the
hero to himself he is the savior and
according to Jeff loveness the Kang
Dynasty is a story about Kang this is
very similar to what they did with
Avengers Infinity War Infinity war was
really a story about Thanos and Thanos
thought that he was setting out to save
his Universe his plan and his people
died due to overpopulation and not
enough resources to go around so Thanos
set out to balance the universe first he
did it physically with his army but then
he sought the Infinity Stones and then
eventually won and we pretty much know
that Kang will win at the end of the
Kang Dynasty that's what's going to lead
us into Secret Wars but according to
Jeff loveness Kang really does believe
that he is the hero and he is even going
up against the other kings and this is
exactly what he warned Ant-Man about in
the movie and this is also what Marvel
Studios president Kevin feige has been
telling us about he's been stating that
it's not just going to be a war between
the Avengers and Kang but it's also
going to be a war between Kang and Kang
other variants of Kang so I think we
might actually have some type of a true
hero with the King that is going to be
in the King Dynasty will he be a hero to
our Avengers probably not considering
that he's probably going to try to kill
them all but our King has told us what
his goal is his goal goal is to win his
goal is to beat those who exiled him the
other Kang variants and what we saw in
the post-credits scene is the three Kang
variants ramatut the Scarlet Centurion
and immortus have somehow weaved their
own timelines together they control many
different timelines and of course we
know that Kang's goal is typically to
rule the entire Multiverse but that
doesn't come without destruction of
other universes this is where it gets
very similar to he who remains and it's
very important to remember what he said
about how the Multiverse War started way
back then he said at first some of the
kings were nice to each other when they
discovered the other universes they
shared a lot of their technology with
each other they helped each other grow
but of course there were variants of
King who were bad and wanted to conquer
the entire Multiverse the multiversal
war broke out and eventually he who
remains killed all of the other
timelines and isolated one and then he
prevented other timelines from being
formed and the reason that he prevented
them from being formed is so his
variants couldn't get out and start
another multiversal War potentially
killing the entire Multiverse and life
as everybody knew it well that could be
what the main Kang and Kang Dynasty is
trying to do trying to prevent the
entire Multiverse from being destroyed
in that sense he very well could be a
hero we only got a brief glimpse of what
Kang has done yes we have seen him
destroy timelines but we don't really
know anything about these timelines
perhaps he was in timelines of the other
kings of very evil versions of Kang and
perhaps he was wiping out those kangs
and those timelines so that they could
never come back and those kings couldn't
threaten the entire Multiverse again in
his mind he has already viewed himself
as the hero he said he's the only one
that can stop what is coming and when
Ant-Man asked what's coming he said me
referring to his other variants who
clearly have a pretty big agenda at
least the three of them it's very clear
that the three variants are in charge a
mortis the Scarlet Centurion and
rabbitut and what's interesting is that
we saw many many people in that Coliseum
cheering for them not only cheering for
them but basically freaking out that it
was them which means they are definitely
willing to do whatever the three of them
tell them and we'll just call them the
Kang Trio so the Kang Trio has an army
and what's scary about that Army is the
Army consists of Kings all with advanced
technology all with time travel
technology the ability to travel through
different points in time and the
Multiverse this is a crazy huge threat a
lot bigger threat than anything we've
ever seen it doesn't just threaten one
universe but all of them and their goal
is to conquer everything and make it
exactly as they want it to be so if
Kang's goal is to defeat them so they
can't do that that does indeed kind of
make him a hero and I'm actually
genuinely excited to hear that this
movie is going to be his story because I
would love to hear more about his past
I'd love to see more and I'd love to see
his justifications for going about and
essentially pruning other timelines and
it will be interesting to hear him
converse with the Avengers explaining
what he is doing essentially this same
conversation that he who remains had
with Loki and Sylvia at the end who will
probably tell them look if you kill me
you will not be able to stop what is
coming there will be infinite numbers of
me coming to invade the entire
Multiverse and there will not be enough
of you to stop them but this might
actually give us a little bit of a clue
on how the King Dynasty is going to end
perhaps The Avengers do end up defeating
Kang and of course that opens up the
other kangs to come and start invading
the entire Multiverse which means The
Avengers will know they have to go to
other universes to find more Heroes to
fight more kangs because of course even
though Kang views himself as a hero he
still is going to be the bad guy is he
doing great work for the Multiverse
probably he who remains did a lot of
great work even though it was viewed as
very bad of course but in reality both
of them wanted the same thing the
Multiverse to not be destroyed and I'm
assuming the ending will be kind of like
Loki they kill him and then they open it
up for everybody else to invade but this
is looking to be like a great movie
already if this is is going to kind of
Shadow what Infinity war did then you
know it's going to be excellent King is
a very intriguing and complex villain
and I'm really looking forward to
learning more about him but let us know
what you think about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf